All right, Sam, we've got the beginnings of a festival app.
>> Yes.
>> And so far, we're keeping track of the festivals.
>> Mm-mm.
>> the attendees, and the stages.
>> Stages.
>> Yeah. So this is good.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But I want more.
[LAUGH]
What do we do next?
>> Yeah, so let's add some complexity into the
app by going into SalesForce but, I mean, as we're
adding in more objects and relationships, it might become
a little bit hazy as to how they're actually related.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And so let's use this new tool called Schema Builder,
which is an easy way for you to not only build
your data model, but also visual see it, and how everything's
related together. kind of similar to what we saw earlier on the tablet
>> Sounds good.
Just click on the Setup link, and then go on
the left-hand side, down the Setup Tree to find Schema Builder.
>> 'Kay, well, there's a lot going on. What are
these, like Content, Activity, what are all these other objects?
>> All of these are, all of the objects
that you have within your Schema. And so these
are the standard objects that we're not even using
in addition to the Festival stuff we've already built.
>> Okay.
>> You can see on the left-hand
side, under the Objects, that you can individually
select which objects you want to see. And the reason you'd want to
see them is you can view all of the different fields, the
relationships between these tables, everything that you might want to see around
your schema, this is kind of like the blueprint of your account.
>> Okay, so I just hit Clear All, and all I
really care about is attendee, like stage and festival for now. Right?
>> Yeah.
>> That's the stuff we've built, and let me zoom in. So, now that this is
a little less of a disaster, and I just have these
three things selected. This is pretty awesome. So, we have festival
here and I can move it around if I want. and
then these little, little line
things that are apparently Master-Detail relationships.
>> Yeah. So you can see that festivals
are related to attendees and stages. And looking
at that little fork you can see that
a festival can have many attendees for many stages
[CROSSTALK].
>>
[CROSSTALK]
Being this little like three, these three things on the side here?
>> Yeah, that little triangle thing at the end.
>> Cool. Okay, so this has, this is great.
This is a visual way to understand my schema.
>> Yeah. And, as you data model get's more
complicated, it will allow you to visualize it really easily.
But, in addition to that, you can add fields
in yourself or create more relationships straight from Schema builder.
>> Okay, so I can just, like I could add a band object
right now?
>> You could. You know, why don't you try that out; see if you can do it.